robert spencer how are the more moderate
sunni states
in the middle east reacting to president
biden's courting of iran
apparently to their detriment and
going against the abrahamic accords well
this is
maybe an unintended paradoxical result
of biden's handlers uh betraying
the sunni allies of the united states
and throwing in their lot with iran
because the sunni states surrounding
iran know that iran's a threat
and so even though biden has repudiate
biden's handlers have repudiated
the abraham accords essentially
and are not encouraging any more accords
to be made between the sunni states and
israel
they may do it anyway because they see
that they have this threat from iran
that's only going to get worse because
of biden's handlers
and so they need to group together and
work together
you